[Musique]
elles sont appelées sorcière dans ce
camp un court qu dans le nord du ghana
vive 113 femmes dans une prison à ciel
ouvert
banni de la société et les sont coupés
de leurs familles sans ressources
après avoir été accusés de sorcellerie
pour cette femme asia foucher unis
l'enfer a commencé il ya six mois quand
des hommes ont encerclé sa maison ils
l'accusent d'avoir tué par sorcellerie
une voisine de son village
j'ai entendu une foule réunie devant
chez moi puis quelqu'un a passé la tête
par dessus le mur et a dit une femme est
morte et 70 fautes c'est toi qui l'a
tuée on va te tuer je lui ai répondu
mais comment j'aurais fait je ne la
connais même pas en cours
pour sauver sa peau elle accepte de
partir et de venir vivre dans ce camp
tatave gala ça qu'on a quand je n'aurais
jamais cru que ça allait m'arriver à moi
qu'un jour je serai accusés de
sorcellerie mal et envoyé ici je ne
crois même pas en la sorcellerie
sans aucun jugement ces femmes sont
condamnées souvent par le chef du
village à vivre recluse dans ces luttes
parfois avec leurs enfants et il n'y a
aucune loi pour interdire cela
deux ong tentent de venir en aide à ces
parias moustapha sy ça travaille pour
l'une d'elles il a lui-même passé toute
son enfance dans ce camp oui madame oif
a tué ma mère a été accusée d'être une
sorcière
en arrivant ici en grandissant j'ai
réalisé que ma mère était innocent
toutes celles qui sont emmenés ici sont
dans la situation de ma mère donc je
compatis avec toutes celles qui sont
accusées de sorcellerie
aujourd'hui il rend visite à la doyenne
du camp
cela fait 33 ans que la tente de
retrouver la liberté
bonjour un cerveau l'après midi comment
allez-vous
son neveu qui lui devait de l'argent l'a
accusée de sorcellerie pour ne pas avoir
à rembourser sa dette
aujourd'hui et d'appels à l'aide pour
pouvoir enfin rentrer chez elle
ici la souffrance est trop grande
je ne trouve même pas à manger
regarde cette racine boulin on doit
tenir avec ça jusqu'à demain c'est trop
dur aucun témoin
comment ça peut aller quand des gens
vous repousse
entre la vie et la mort
mustapha recueille quelques informations
sur la vieille femme pour ensuite aller
plaider sa cause dans son ancien village
et obtenir son retour
une partie du travail de ce défenseur
c'est justement de se rendre dans les
communautés de la région pour faire
changer les mentalités
ici la sorcellerie vise essentiellement
les femmes c'est un moyen de les écarter
lorsqu'elle devienne gênante pour une
raison ou pour une autre comme un couple
si ça ne va pas la femme finira par être
accusés de sorcellerie pas vrai
personne ici ne peut jurer que cette
femme ne se retrouvera pas dans un camp
sauf si on arrête ses bêtises mais les
trois quarts de la population au ghana
croit en la sorcellerie la tâche est
difficile mais sasp et ils soupçonnent
les sorcières d'avoir fait du tort alors
communauté alors ils ne sont pas encore
prêts à les faire revenir chez hertz
ailleurs nous avons réussi en
réhabiliter une cinquantaine mais ici
c'est la première fois qu'on vient c'est
plus difficile
le ghana est officiellement le dernier
pays au monde à abriter ces camps de
sorcières en 2014 une commission
nationale a été chargée de les fermer
mais elle s'est heurtée aux croyances
locales et a échoué il reste aujourd'hui
cinq camps à travers le pays dans lequel
vivent 300 femmes